i am currently the acting president of
afghanistan the president has fled and
according to the constitution i am the
acting uh president of the country
well what you see in kabul is a
the tiny fraction of the tragedy
unfolding in my country because of a
wrong
decision political decision that was
taken in washington
disregarding the ground reality
they legitimized taliban through the doh
attacks and they created an agreement
which was violated word by word by the
taliban
and now we are seeing the consequences
america should show a sprint it should
not show weakness and it should not bow
to terrorism
if they want to adhere to the 31st
august deadline
that means
leaving afghans to their debts
and also not taking the taliban to the
account and leaving the pakistanis to
get away
with their campaign with the backing of
the campaign of terror of the afghans
so the world has an obligation morally
politically and legally
not to leave a mess in my country and
still use it as a
diplomatic power
to create a political settlement
mr i'm going to jump in there if you say
you are the acting president of your
country where are you where is your
government and where is your army
according to the constitution if i have
three elements under my control i am the
acting president
planned people and control i have all
those three elements we have land under
our control we have people who support
us
and we are controlling the situation
i am less than
suicide
attack
go ahead sir please i apologize for
interrupting you go ahead sir
yes i am 30 kilometers less than 30
kilometers
uh north of the background air base
i am in the panchayat valley and we have
a footer resistance not in this valley
but in the surrounding valley
and it doesn't matter what is the size
of the territory we control
legally i'm the acting president of
afghanistan and uk
as a as a country priding itself by rule
of law
and by
adhering to the constitution it's very
important
that this should be acknowledged that
the afghan constitution has not
abrogated it has been invaded
it has been desecrated by a terrorist
group but it is still being upheld
by the second person in power and that's
myself
what is your plan now sir
my plan we have offered
a taliban to negotiate meaningfully or
if they choose to fight
we are
we are willing to to resist people are
supporting us
we have uh
we have
so far
mobilized the people the afghans have
zero trust in the taliban
as i said kabul airport is just
tip off the iceberg that's not the size
of the disaster you are seeing if the
taliban are
having any type of support in the afghan
population why people are fleeing
and why people have no trust in them so
therefore i am calling again which has
an obligation morally politically
legally
to stay engaged
with the right afghans
and they should acknowledge that i have
not played
i have not
accepted that shame
and that humiliation
and that disgrace to leave my people in
these difficult circumstances
we have started a resistance and we have
turned pine share into a sanctuary for
the oppressed for those who are not
harassing the taliban and i am telling
you if people have difficulty flying
from kabul airport our doors are open to
them we will greet them with honor and
dignity and if need be we will defend
them with our blood
and with our bones
so if if by them cannot evacuate all the
people and in danger by august 31 we
invite all those people in danger at
risk of being killed or massacred by the
taliban to take refuge in the financial
value it is part of their country
okay mr salah thank you very much for
talking to us